the other week the annual summer games
done quick speed running charity
marathon wrapped up it was an incredible
event there were some really really
awesome speedruns and they raised over 3
million dollars for doctors without
borders
but in the days after the event ended
people found out that one of the
speedrunners faked his run live on
stream and now daniel from last week is
gonna explain this whole thing to you
alright folks before we get into the
video i want to ask you to please subs
the channel and turn on notifications if
you haven't done it yet and you can head
over to our twitch channel at twitch.tv
score esports and follow us there
because we're streaming all the time and
you don't want to miss a stream okay so
this one is kind of personal for me i
love speedrunning i watched both gdqs
every year and i used to force everyone
in the office to watch them with me
every year because i was the only person
who controlled the tvs back when we you
know all sat in the same room and this
year i was super excited to see that for
the first time since 2014 there was
going to be a middle year rising revenge
and speedrun at sgdq metal gear rising
is a spin-off of the metal gear solid
games released in 2013 where you play as
a cyborg ninja and use an electric sword
to cut dudes into a million pieces it
rules and it's been seeing a bit of a
resurgence online lately partly because
it was weirdly prescient about the
current political situation in america
and also because it's hilarious
[Music]
making the mother of all omelets here
jack can't fret over every egg so i was
super hyped to see macaroni a russian
speedrunner run metal gear rising this
year and during his initial new game
plus hard mode run of the game the
community raised enough money to unlock
another rising speed run a quick shot
through the game's blade wolf dlc on the
highest difficulty setting revengeance
but after mecharazim finished his blade
wolf run people noticed some
weird things for example there is this
clip where macarasium raises his right
hand notably the hand he uses for his
mouse while the camera is moving on
stream there's also the fact that his ng
plus hard mode run of the game was full
of clicky keyboard noises in the
background while the blade wolf run was
suspiciously silent and one of the
strangest things is that when the run
ended despite getting a world record
this was his reaction holy
um
um kind of like a world record yes
but hey can we
like not
use the world record stuff right
because like you see it's very
misleading and uh it assumes that the
video that i've done here is the fastest
time when in fact someone else could
have a faster andric unrecorded version
can you please use the term symbite
also known as currently best known time
with public early available evidence
created by
uh like someone else that follows the
rules of the speedrunning community a
specific game that has been verified and
improved by members of speedway and
community that has considered moderators
all spiritual
moderate future in the future i believe
this would lower
your confusion right yeah it was a
little weird also you'll notice that he
said this video that i've done here when
talking about his run and remember that
because we're gonna get back to it later
anyway he followed his bizarre anti-pop
off with this rant about what's become
of speedrunning culture a lot of people
in many
communities care
not about the way to make their runs
good but instead to make them run
good on the leaderboard
no matter the cost i feel empty seeing
deranged
denied one last epiphany and ushered
from the stage
we won't be meeting again i think some
people just want to see this world burn
good night
every mall there will be more godless
nights and a few days after the run
ended anybody who was suspicious of
mecharazim's run was justified because
it turns out
he wasn't playing the game live on
stream at all he was streaming a video
of his best runs at each section of the
dlc spliced together to make it look
like one contiguous run which does
explain the part where he called it a
video on stream technically he did still
play the game but he didn't play it live
and he didn't play it as one solid run
usually speedrunning communities like to
separate segment that runs like this
into their own category he was acting
out his speedrun the whole time which is
both one of the dumbest things i've ever
heard but also kind of admirable like he
definitely committed to the bat no no no
no
perfect
so here we're gonna aggro the a couple
of enemies and the dog here which allows
me to skip the fight and if quickly
quickly go to this panel and activate it
without triggering the fight we can
easily go here so then there is a couple
of other manipulations to do so first of
all we aggro the enemy on the right so
we make sure to park her across him like
this and we're going to touch the panel
without do not kill me i'm going to
smaller if you though pc games n
reported that mcarazian posted in an
official gdq discord after the event
admitting the run was not live in the
message he states that the blade wolf
dlc was a pre-recorded segmented run but
that he didn't tell anyone that during
the submission process or before the
stream apparently it was gonna be real
time but he changed his mind last minute
which is wild to me given that he had to
have a whole video prepared anyway if he
wanted to do this it seems like it was a
pre-planned cheat mecarazim said that he
did a quote very bad thing that he
shouldn't have done and he acted
selfishly because the ng plus run went
so well and he just wanted to do
something even better to top it off
notably mecharazim was dreaming from
home the last couple of gtq events have
seen people stream their speedruns from
home because of covid and sgdq was the
first event where people could play from
the gdq venue again a few speedrunners
were allowed to stream from home though
and some members of the community are
worried that because one person used
that allowance to cheat future events
won't let people who can't make it
stream from their homes in a statement
given by games done quick to pc game n
gdq explained that they have banned
mkharazim from all future events and
removed his runs from the youtube
channel yesterday we were made aware
that mecca rossium played a segmented
video for his dlc run at summer games
done quick 2022. mkharazim has since
admitted to this both to some members of
the community as well as directly to gdq
staff he contacted our staff with a
document detailing that he had planned
this for over a month demonstrating this
was planned and intentional this was
made possible because of the remote
nature of this particular run in the
marathon this is absolutely unacceptable
and attempts to undermine the integrity
of the speedrunning community that we
love and support the exact result they
desired was unclear for the document but
it is clear that they believed we would
not be willing to speak out about their
behavior however we believe that it is
in the community's best interest to know
why this run was removed by gdq we have
removed mkhirazium's runs from our
youtube archive and will not permit him
to run in the future speaking to
kotaku's ethan gatch mecharazim admitted
it was a scummy thing to do but also
doubled down on some of his
anti-speedrun culture stuff from the end
of the fake run mecha rosium had this to
say to kotaku this is a taunt a taunt to
every single person that watches
speedrunning events and haven't asked
yourself some questions if you want to
see some things change there's always a
price to pay i am paying with my
reputation of a marathon runner a
speedrunner a commentator and a very
passionate person to make others think
about the things you're ready to do in
the name of said passion so that others
might change their opinion on the
speedrunning as a whole mecha rosium
also spoke out on reddit saying quote
you've missed the idea of the speech at
the end instead of going he cheated
route which has no meaning as the run
was never intended to be on the
leaderboards and at least one person
knew that i was doing one i advise you
to think a little bit out of the box and
try to connect the dots to see if the
speech will have more meaning to it not
going to elaborate it any further that
reddit thread by the way is full of
people being angry confused and even
upset by all this if you boil it down
while gdq isn't a competitive event
people are tuning in and donating money
because they like watching fun speed
runs and if you find out it's all fake
then what's the point of watching and if
nobody's watching nobody's donating to
these charities and you've kind of
destroyed the whole event plus speed
running is a niche hobby in the first
place cheating scandals can impact it
heavily either getting people not to
watch or even driving people not to play
like i spent two months of my
life trying to improve myself for my run
and then you just completely the
bed and ruin it for everyone the speed
running community is obviously not
thrilled with what happened here and big
name speedrunner grand pooh bear even
watched the run on his stream and
commented on it i gotta i gotta pause
this for a second i
hate when people criticize
the people who run for a time on the
leaderboard you can speedrun for fun you
can speed run for competition you can
speed around to get a world record and
all of them are completely legit like
yes there's a billion unsung heroes and
every i i i've been the first one to
talk about that like i've i've benefited
from so many other people's routing all
the time like yes
that's
absolutely true but like your problem
isn't with those people your problem
isn't with speedrunning your problems
just with like what people enjoy
watching look this isn't speedrunning's
first scandal and it will not be its
last but what's really weird and damning
about this whole situation is that it
happened on speedrunning's biggest stage
and that the guy who did it is actually
good like his ng plus hard run of rising
ended with a 57-54 time which would be
the 17th best run on the leaderboard if
he submitted it mechazaryam is a
legitimately good speedrunner he's
actually still the number one ranked
blade wolf runner in the world with a
656 time submitted just a few days after
gdq that's a second faster than his
segmented run from the event and the
messed up thing is that i don't know if
that run is legit or not like it's
absolutely possible that he's a good
runner and picked up a real world record
just a few days after his fake one but
it's also possible that he cheated again
and i have no way of knowing all of his
runs are going to hold this stigma
forever and potentially drag the entire
metal gear rising speedrun community
down with him this is why cheating is
bad even when money isn't on the line it
destroys the integrity of a hobby that
so many people love was he really trying
to make a statement on speedrunning
culture and how he thinks people are too
obsessed with leaderboards was he really
trying to bring focus to all the people
behind the scenes who don't have world
records was he trying to show what would
be possible in this category with
perfect human play was he trying to
one-up his previous speedrun was he just
trolling it's all so weird and i have no
idea but what i do know is that he
mostly made himself look ridiculous and
also he added another clip to the
endless cheating speedrunners who got
caught montages on youtube
this game is crazy but the the main
villain is a us senator and his goal is
to turn the intel like basically
everybody in america into a gun-toting
soldier and uh when you fight him he he
knocks you off his like you know giant
robot platform and he then he yells i'm
gonna make america great again this was
2013 truly
mind-blowing in that video game